just last year Samsung introduced a TV
with a twist or more like a curve while
the rest of us are just about gotten
used to flat screens the idea behind
this was it offered optimum viewing with
better color and contrast the viewers
eye is the same distance from every part
of the screen now
Samsung has made it Bend it's both flat
screen and it's curved screen depending
how many people are watching in front of
it yep so you can basically optimize
this to your reviewing behavior as you
are preferring it to the most motors
changed the shape of the screen which
flexes it's the latest in the range of
curved and ultra high definition TVs
from the South Korean firm which while
still quite new it says are selling well
we were sure of course it would be a
success but only six months after
introduction every second UHD TV we are
selling is the curved UHD TV now the
ephah tech show in Berlin there's always
got to be a standout product that some
from the tech community aren't so sure
this is it the funny thing about the
bendable TV it kind of removes the USP
all for the curved TV it's for those
people that have got more money than
sense a lot of the time Samsung are
undoubtedly first with this idea and
while impressive it could be more about
showing off its huge levels of
innovation in all things electronic Tom
Gibson Bloomberg